All right, let's let's hear from some people
in the audience.
This is the last opportunity before next week's
election.
Want to see what's on people's minds, of course,
now.
But using the David Pakman show discords server,
which you can find at David Pakman dot com
slash discord and lots of great conversation
happening there.
Otherwise, let's first go to let's go to Ali
from Detroit.
Ali from Detroit.
You were on.
What's going on there?
What's on your mind today?
Ali from Detroit, please, on mute.
And you can talk to me.
Sorry, can you hear me now?
Yes, I can.
I'm a big fan.
Thank you.
I was calling today because I wanted to ask,
like, what do you think about the filibuster?
And what's the likelihood that that will actually
get repealed under like a Biden administration?
Because I have my doubts that that the filibuster
will leave.
It will even be gone.
But I have the same doubts.
I have seen so on unexpended the court.
I now feel very strongly Joe Biden should
do it.
I don't buy the slippery slope arguments.
I think it's completely warranted, given the
way Republicans have dealt with the Supreme
Court over the last four years.
I think it's time and I don't buy, as I mentioned
in a commentary earlier this week, that every
president that now is going to expand the
court on the filibuster.
I've seen better arguments for both sides.
But I think the arguments will be moot because
I like you don't really think Joe Biden is
going going to push for it.
OK.
Oh, and another other thing I was gonna ask
you is, so do you think we could actually,
like, make a progressive movement through
a Biden administration?
Because I feel like after hearing AOC talk
earlier this week and saying how she's planning
to lobby him towards her agenda when it comes
to fracking.
I just kind of have my doubts that she'll
leave and or that anything like that will
get done.
We'll remember Joe Biden's Joe Biden's idea.
You know, Trump has made this big deal out
of Joe said he would ban fracking and then
Joe said he wouldn't.
Biden's actual plan is to put us on a path
to get to 100 percent renewables, which would
simply phase out fracking.
And everybody's focused on is Biden going
to try to pass a law to make it illegal in
six months?
No, he's not going to do that in either case.
The point is a framework where we get away
from fracking anyway.
And so I don't see AOSIS position as completely
antithetical to Biden's.
Anyway, the point is, will, will he have the
Senate and what can he actually get through
as a result of that?
I think it's less about his ambitions than
whether it's actually feasible with the Senate.
OK.
You know.
That's that's all I had to ask you today.
I'm a big fan.
I'm glad I got
to
talk
to you.
All right.
Ali from Detroit, appreciate hearing from
you.
Thank you so much.